let's see if we remember it if you have
a line right so this is sort of quarter
geometry speaking right any line you
like let's just say its gradient is ever
now I've destroyed this particular one
and just as an example going through the
origin so its gradient is M what's its
equation y equals MX okay now if I think
about what I'm after is this acute angle
that's formed actually not acute angle
the angle formed between this axis here
what does negotiate this axis near the
positive x axis and the light itself so
I'm interested in this angle of
elevation if you like okay so how can I
go about finding it what we'll do is
we'll take advantage of some about
really simple year by right angle tree
and construct a running a triangle here
okay so what might be the most useful
triangle to construct if we make a
triangle of starting from say that x
intercept there right and move forward
one unit okay now I'm just going to zoom
in and make my one unit really large so
where's that point there is one so this
is going to be a triangle with base one
okay now if I construct my right angle
triangle here okay because that's a
straight vertical moment going off the
coordinate at that point would be well
the x coordinate would be 1 and we use
someone in to this your Y value will be
and that simply means that corresponds
to the fact that gradient is rise over
run right and once so if this base down
here is and because the quack when it's
M that means that load is okay remember
what we were after was theta so this is
where that familiar result
comes out from tan theta is opposite on
adjacent okay so you often see it
written in Reverse what equation and
equals you know okay so that's simple
stuff now by the way I put this line
just because of it was convenient I put
it through the origins what would happen
if I have you suppose it was X must be
and it was like move up or move sideways
or something like that what difference
will it make
and so there's no difference at all
right I'm having a vertical or
horizontal shift moneygrab machine fell
you want it did a finish it finish
didn't know anywhere what was I saying
having our vertical horizontal shift
doesn't change us at all okay because
these distances and that angle will
still relate to each other in exactly
the same way sorry all right so let's
take that draw another diagram beneath
this and let's shift it to an angle
between two lines which is what we're
really interested in
now when you look at these two lines
France Russia and some of our mixture
things on my axes generally what they're
looking for is the acute angle in fact
the question will usually be phrase find
the acute angle between these two lines
okay occasionally they'll want the
obtuse angle but I'll show you how to
get that later on it's actually quite
simple but in this case the treatment
laughter the theta right is in between
yeah and you can probably see it like
that angle is vertically opposite this
angle so those are the same it doesn't
matter which one the acute angle there's
only one of them okay the same cases
yeah how can I relate this to that right
well this angle is related to this angle
from each line okay so since I'll call
it theta for that angle to be two words
it's called the other angles different
names so for instance if that's how far
in the corner and that's video okay so
we know how to work out each of these
lines of we know the gradients of the
loans that they correspond to okay so
suppose this Mikey the one with an angle
alpha so pause I had a gradient m1 okay
and you can see I've put them in
different intercepts so I really should
say plus a new say b1 that'll be its way
into Center and that's called the other
lines ready in - and of course it has a
different y-intercept of course wants to
wherever it it's okay sir how do I get
theta in terms of alpha beta what's the
most direct way that relates those
the feet that's exactly right a second
lab we're on the bullets could be the
thing if what you read is the exterior
angles are triangle then that is the
right thing so what are you gonna have
here right feet out the exterior angle
of this triangle okay beater is equal to
theta plus alpha okay and I might as
well say exterior angle I really should
say it equals the sum of the officer to
interior angles but I think you gave us
talking about okay so therefore hook in
this case right feeder is actually equal
to B minus sorry beta minus alpha okay
all right now how can that I get from
via where other from here to something
meaningful out of this right well
relating the angle and the gradient
requires that tan ratio right so I'm
going to take tan of both sides okay but
you guys know the expansion for this so
we can actually break this out beta
minus alpha so which one's going to be
the plus and which one's going to be the
- but the top will be the - okay so this
is going to be 10 feet up - in alpha
right and at the bottom because that was
the - this will be the plus they say 1
plus now the great thing about this the
reason why this is actually useful and
not that gross is because I know what
Teddy from 10 alpha and beta are in
terms of these gradients okay so because
alpha is here I can say 10 alpha is that
gradient okay you can see how it's
really just follow that left and tan
beta is the other great unit okay so if
I just do a substitution here what I've
got is
to minus M 1 over 1 plus into what or if
I swap this around okay I would write it
as M 1 minus M ok now that's that's the
result ok tan theta that is the angle
between the two lines
that's the result now before we start
using it okay I want to address the
question how do you know which one to
put first is it this one
or is it this one now I want to all know
that questions sit in your mind for a
second which one do I use which which
gradient do I put first and let's have a
look at an example question ok